いいいいいい
なーさーらーんローカーローラックオーロラペローナロ楼羅老なすグラノーラつば
ローラー撮ろうなやれ
で写した今日反する頭痛でいっぱい
俺はこれこんなときを待っていたああ
くら寿司常にくら寿司が我々の業界になのでを挙げたなんとですね何度ですよ
無添くら寿司から
ん
流動が発表されました素晴らしいでございます下だねその出し方やを出し方というかね
キャッチがすごかった370円で売ってたんですけども今回このキャラとして販売され
た牛丼の名前が牛道を超えた牛丼
とりあえず出て北牛丼大好きなんですよきっと視聴者の皆様の中に流動屋さんで僕に
合った人結構いると思います覚えてるか
そんな話はどうでもいい流動本当に好きなんで私宮どうこういった球団っていうことが
いいか里の者だっていうのはちょっと確かなきゃいけないどうか hot k ので
今回このクラウド市の牛丼を持ち上げて家庭も来ずにも使って講義変えてきたわけで
ございます今日の夜は今回この無添くら寿司で買った牛どう超えた牛取ったらもの曲の
中で箱でそのレビュー遅いと思っておりますで愛子
hi-ho いたってシンプルな鍵水上を割とちゃんとした牛丼ですね牛肉とあ普通に
ケースはずそうなんでケース外す前で説明すればなかなかしっかりした牛丼ですねあ
まねきもちゃんと味か聴いてるみたいでございますね良い大事だよ
もうなるほど個人的には結構よし度やよりです吉野家よりの匂いがします果たして虎角
方理佳とのことだ
新座じっしょなるほど包囲しそうだなドミじゃあ
いただきます
うわっなんでこの味は今までに存在していた牛豚の店舗には感じることができなかった
豊かな風味が肉の煮込み時間が違うからであろうこれは7時間ほどに媚びるとに串屋さ
んっていうだけあってますがこの牛肉
ライダーすぐ焦げる初級とか柔らかい舌触りの牛肉天海が溢れんばかりに来する中を
豊かにしてくれるたマネー
この十分
バサ姉
この柔道まさにっ
gp #著
ok と超えてはいないぞ公園てば言いません
柔道は越えてはいない間違いない恋じゃないないでも生まれる
お米もまさか酢飯使ってじゃねぇかなと思ったけど酢飯も使ってなくしいて言うなら
結構やっぱり吉野家よりです見る t なぜかします天海が効いてますね甘くて食べ
やすいから多分で子どもたちを普通に好きですねこのタイプは
うん
きっ
うんうん
うまかったごちそうさまでした大抵指で食べてみたんですけども
馬市は美味しいハード石が誰がなぜお寿司屋さんで出してたという謎
味はよく出来てたと思います人に柔道家さんの柔道に引けを取らない美味しさでした
めっちゃ真面目にレポートしてるなって美味しかったよ
ちょっとこの牛堂前にスタートしてはやっぱ結局4渋谷が好きなんですよ実はてげ皆
さんもぜひよかったら旧道を超えた牛丼を食べてみてくださいこういうているかどうか
はちらでいいけどな
じゃん
もう一個食べよ
me
あっはぁ